whether it's languages or business you
gotta connect you gotta connect emotion
while you're negotiating in the evening
when you go out and have dinner with
them or drink a beer with them and
language learning is all about
enthusiasm curiosity enthusiasm
motivation in fact you need to get the
language in you first through massive
listening and reading so that then
grammar explanations might start to make
sense to you you can't start with the
grammar this guy's willing to take the
time to learn our language maybe he's
going to be more detailed about working
with us I think the biggest thing about
speaking languages is that more
opportunities are going to come your way
it makes it easier to communicate with
people to persuade people to establish
relationships with people and we all
know that in business Communications
relationships are extremely important